- So is monogamy a bad
thing in your opinion?
- Long-term sexual
monogamy is not congruent
with our species.
I look at monogamy as being
akin to vegetarianism.
- So like annoying.
- Potentially annoying.
- Okay.
- You can choose to be a
vegetarian,
but you are still an omnivore.
You can't choose to be an
herbivore.
- Yes.
- They're still gonna smell the
barbecue.
It's still gonna smell good.
- Pretty much we're made to
like fuck a lot of people.
- Exactly.
- So I'm here today because I
want to find
a girl for my boyfriend to have
sex with.
You don't think that I'm like
weird?
- No, I think you're weird, of
course.
- Everyone who's been
disapproving of this,
my therapist, my mom, God.
Even worse, Dr. Drew.
- Dr. Drew?
- Dr. Drew told me not to do it.
- But Dr. Dre is find with it.
- Dr. Dre would be fine with it.
(laughter)
- Society doesn't approve of
this,
but hey, five years ago,
society didn't approve
of medical marijuana.
It didn't approve gay marriage.
It didn't approve a lot of
things.
Society needs to grow up.
So I think what you're doing is
good.
It's revolutionary.
It's important.
- A lot of people who
have told me I should
not be doing this say,
"You're gonna be jealous."
- Which makes perfect sense.
There's a heightened sense
of connecting with the person
because there's maybe a danger
that you're losing them.
- So it's a risk, you know?
- Yeah, like rock climbing.
- Exactly.
And I'm just picking the
rock he's going to climb
and have sex with.
So you think that it's maybe
healthy for my relationship.
- If it's something that
you both want to do,
then why not, yeah.
The hell with Dr. Drew.
- Thank you.
- Good luck.
- Hello, hi.
- Hey, how's it going?
- [Blonde girl] Nikki?
- Yes.
- [Blonde girl] Hi, nice to meet
you.
- Likewise.
- I'm interviewing you
to date my boyfriend.
- Yes.
- Okay.
If you get the job..
- [Brunette girl] Mm-hmm.
- You and my boyfriend can
go and do whatever it is
you two wanna do, no questions
asked.
- And you're okay with that?
- Yeah, I am.
Tell me why you would be
good for this position.
- I know how to please a man.
- I am super funny.
- How funny are you?
Because that's kind of my thing.
- Oh, yeah.
Not funnier than you.
- Okay, okay.
What do you look for in a guy?
- I like 'em tall.
- I really like black guys.
- I'm cool with that, too.
Boom.
- Hello.
This is your boyfriend?
Damn.
- [Blonde girl] Yeah.
- Hit it, man, his straight-ass
teeth.
- Would you lick those teeth?
- I would honestly suck the
white out of that guy's teeth.
- You got a hottie on your
hands.
- You could sit on that.
- I could sit on that, yeah.
- Okay.
Could sit on.
My boyfriend knows what's wrong
with me,
so what is wrong with you?
- I'm hard-headed.
I'm a bull.
I'm Taurus.
- Oh, so you're into astrology.
- [Girl on right] A little bit.
- That's what's wrong with you,
okay.
How good at sex are you?
- Awesome.
- I'm really good at sex.
- Like how good?
- I do porn.
- You do porn?
- Yeah.
I actually did my first
interracial gang bang
like a week ago.
- So did I.
- Everybody's doing it.
- Now, tell me, what is
your like best skill in bed?
- The cowboy on top maybe.
- Way too spicy.
On a scale of a limp handshake
to a like vice grip pliers,
like how tight are you?
- Oh, I'm pretty tight.
- Really?
- Yeah, I'm really little.
- It's actually tighter
than I'd like it to be.
- You wish you weren't as tight.
Oh, you poor thing.
- Actually, it's itty-bitty.
Itty-bitty kitty.
- Mine looks like it's trying to
escape.
Do you ever have that feeling?
- No, I haven't.
- Can you give me an example of
a sound
you would make during sex?
- Uh, uh, uh,
oh, God, yeah.
Is that good?
- No.
(laughter)
Fuck.